le décompte de commencer pour les
festivités de la Fête nationale la fin
de semaine prochaine et la controverse
frappe le Parti québécois a annoncé
aujourd'hui qu'il déclinait l'invitation
de prononcer un discours au spectacle de
vendredis sur les Plaines d'Abraham
pourquoi parce que l'animateur de la
soirée ne fait pas son affaire c'est
qu'il animateur c'est le chanteur Émile
Bilodeau qui a déjà souhaité la mort du
Parti québécois qui a qualifié les
députés du PQ de pleurnicheur sur la
question du serment au roi qui est
résolument Québec solidaire dans son
affiliation politique et qui a déjà dit
de la loi sur la laïcité qu'il est
misogyne islamophobe et dégradante on
leur demandera pas de chanter nettoyer
mais on va leur demander de commenter
Michel cocher Jean-François lisier
Dimitri soudain c'est Françoise Boivin
bon début d'après-midi et bon début de
semaine bonjour bonjour salut ok alors
ça se fait aller sur les réseaux sociaux
ce matin j'ai un match de ping-pong
entre
défenseur des Mille bilodeaux et
critique des Mille bilodeaux voici ce
que Megane périmelançon du Parti
québécois qui était supposé pendant une
discours à a écrit Émile Bilodeau est un
artiste qui est entièrement libre de
dire et de chanter tout ce qui lui
tendent incluant de critiquer eux-mêmes
d'insulter des politiciens la question
ici c'est pourquoi le mouvement national
des Québécois la désigné comme
porte-parole de l'événement alors qu'il
a non seulement dénigré mon chef mais
souhaiter la mort du Parti québécois est
tenu des propos sur la laïcité qui sont
tout sauf rassemblement réplique des
1000 Bilodeau lui-même se sert des
réseaux sociaux pour dire bonne saison
cher ami répond à Mégane Perry Mélenchon
je vais animer chanter et danser mon
amour pour le Québec pendant deux heures
sur les Plaines d'Abraham le 23 juin
bref on va vous faire un estime bon show
si vous voulez me consoler je vous
propose d'aller voir ce que font les
républicains aux États-Unis ils ont de
l'expérience dans le domaine suivi de
trois bisous
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la décision
du pays
je ne la comprends pas pour être honnête
avec vous
j'ai de la misère à comprendre comment
le Parti québécois sera absent de la
fête nationale
puis je suis d'accord avec eux peut-être
que 1000 Bilodeau malgré le fait qu'il
est jeune malgré le fait qu'il est
souverainiste
n'est pas quelqu'un qui a voté pour le
Parti québécois lors de la dernière
élection mais c'est aussi le cas dans
125 sur 125 circonscriptions donc est-ce
que le PQ va ignorer tout ce et celle
qui ont peut-être souhaité la mort du PQ
qui peut-être non pas voté pour le PQ et
finalement aller au célèbration sur les
Plaines d'Abraham le 24 juin le 23 juin
au soir c'est pas pour aimer le Bilodeau
c'est c'est pour la nation québécoise
c'est pour le peuple québécois c'est
pour fêter la fête nationale donc si
Émile Bilodeau n'aime pas le PQ et le PQ
n'importe mais ils ont pas besoin de
prendre une bière ensemble mais je pense
que le a besoin de prendre des bières
avec le plus de Québécois possible
regardez la porte-parole du PQ qui dit
moi je je ne serai pas là c'est une
ancienne députée du PQ qui a été défaite
et malgré le protocole d'ici les élus
qui s'adressent les élus qui prennent la
parole le MNQ donne la parole et offre
la parole à quelqu'un qui n'est pas élu
au nom du Parti québécois parce qu'ils
ont seulement bien sûr trois députés
donc je pense qu'il devrait mettre de
côté leurs différences avec Émile
Bilodeau et se dire il y aurait des
dizaines de milliers de Québécois le 23
au soir c'est à eux qu'on veut parler
c'est c'est c'est leur main qu'on veut
serrer et ici aussi c'est eux qu'on veut
convaincre
ultimement de de retourner au Parti
québécois donc le snob envers Émile
Bilodeau pour moi c'est un snob c'est un
snob envers tous ceux et celles qui
seront là le 23 au soir et le PQ dit non
bon nous on pleurniche parce que 1000
Bilodeau on l'aime pas il nous aime pas
puis insulter mon chef
Jean-François
ce serait un excellent argument Dimitri
si c'était le cas mais la porte-parole
du PQ n'a pas été invitée à prendre la
parole pendant le spectacle au milieu de
téléspectateurs mais seulement à la
petite cérémonie à côté où il y aura une
centaine de personnes donc effectivement
le calcul de risque que tu proposes
était le bon si ça avait été vrai moi je
leur ai dit mais franchement oublié puis
aller parler puis montrer mes gammes qui
est extraordinaire
à une très grande assemblée mais c'est
pas le cas c'est comme la même chose
lorsque ce sera à Montréal parce qu'elle
Bérubé sera présent pour représenter le
PQ au fait national de Montréal mais il
parlera pas sur la scène non plus c'est
pas c'est pas ça l'invitation alors ça
fait deux semaines que ça percole moi
quand j'ai commencé à voir ça c'est
d'avoir le mouvement pour laïcité qui
s'est exprimé contre le choix de
Bilodeau puis ma réaction c'est dire
écoute c'est pas grave là si il était
contre la loi 21 puis l'important c'est
que on chante tous la fête nationale etc
c'est pas des désaccords respectueux il
a souhaité la mort du PQ il a dit que la
loi vous l'avez dit Sébastien la loi 21
était dégradante et
misogyne c'est ce sont des positions
extrêmes qu'il a prises alors le MNQ
savait aujourd'hui le l'embarras du
choix des porte-paroles c'est pas comme
si il y avait une liste de trois
personnes il y en a parlé du choix j'ai
choisi quelqu'un dont on pouvait dire
que
la façon qu'il a exprimé son désaccord
n'est pas respectueuse n'est pas
rassembler c'est ça on peut pas on peut
pas mettre ça en cause maintenant même
dans sa réaction à la missile de Mégane
il me lançons qui dit moi il est pas
question que je le cancelle il est pas
question que je ne demande pas un mètre
cube de le retirer
pas le droit d'être là mais moi j'ai le
droit de pas y aller et là bilodo répond
ah oui vous êtes comme des républicains
qui essayaient de me canceller mais t'as
même pas lu la lettre tiens je dis il me
semble que dedans contexte tu devrais
avoir une réaction rassembleuse et pas
faire des procès d'intention faux à
cette personne-là qui dit écoute voulu
que mon chef t'as voulu comparti
disparaisse t'as traité mon chef de
pleurnichat ça me tente pas d'y aller
alors je comprends une autre décision
était possible mais franchement à mesure
que j'ai vu les déclarations de Bilodeau
puis ensuite celle de ce matin me dit
franchement je comprends je comprends
très bien
est-ce que vous comprenez comme
Jean-François
je vous avoue là moi cette histoire que
Jean-François raison qui percole depuis
deux semaines premièrement bravo PQ il y
a encore trouvé une façon d'avoir
beaucoup de visibilité alors qu'il y en
aurait pas tellement compte tenu de du
petit nombre de députés à leur
disposition pour aller célébrer toutes
les fêtes nationales un peu partout sur
le territoire québécois moi c'est drôle
au tout début je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez il y avait l'histoire du Palais
des Congrès et l'histoire d'Émile
bilodeaux pratiquement en même temps et
j'aimerais réfléchir à différentes
choses me poser des questions souvent
pas faciles voir aller au bout de ma
pensée puis de mes convictions et en
même temps me dire ben des fois mes
convictions sont pas celles des autres
et dans ce contexte là c'est aussi ça le
Québec il faut accepter la diversité
je respecte le choix du mouvement
national des Québécois c'est c'est leur
choix le plus ces autres qui vont vivre
et périr avec leur choix c'est un jeune
qui est populaire qui est un excellent
animateur c'est sur ça qu'ils espèrent
justement que ça va amener les gens on
s'en va fêter on va pas faire de la
politique et là je vais vous faire ma
montée de lait ça fait longtemps que
j'ai une grosse crotte sur le coeur moi
par rapport à la fête nationale des
Québécois vous savez je me considère
avant tout québécoise très fier de
l'être très fier des Canadiennes mais
très fiers d'être québécoises et lorsque
j'ai été élu en 2004 au mois de juin et
que l'année d'après on fait une grosse
célébration à Gatineau en fait mais
aussi la célébration officielle
parrainée par le gouvernement du Québec
et qui t'invite pas parce que tu es pas
piqué sous t'es pas bloqué ben je vous
avoue que c'est extrêmement frustrant
que ça censuré
vous étiez pas invité au célébrations
lorsqu'ils étaient députés se faire à
éviter et ainsi de suite alors quitte
pas on dirait que ça envoie le message
que tu es pas aussi québécois que les
autres et ici moi au contraire je trouve
qu'en mettant Émile Bilodeau qui a
obtenu des idées très différentes des
miennes en matière de laïcité en matière
de plein de choses en matière de
souveraineté je ne lui enlève pas le
droit de participer à une à une soirée à
une célébration qui n'est pas qui ne
devrait pas on se passe notre vie à dire
que la scène nationale des Québécois ça
ne devrait pas être une fête politique
et dans des plages à mon ami
Jean-François j'ai toujours senti moi
peut-être 14 vous me direz peut-être que
j'ai l'épiderme sensible mais j'ai
souvent senti que ce on essaie de ne pas
en faire on essayait de dire non si tu
n'es pas souvenu si tu n'es pas
d'affaires dans nos choses alors de voir
le Parti québécois qui qui semble
ressentir des choses que j'ai peut-être
ressentir à l'époque je vous dis pas
parce que je suis pas mesquine de nature
je vous dis pas que ça m'a fait un petit
boulot
et j'ai appris à vivre avec ça et j'ai
appris
que je m'assume je pense par dessus
c'est pas des imbéciles qui vont
m'empêcher de célébrer ma fête nationale
alors j'encourage madame vous glissons
non à célébrer comme tous les autres et
puis essayer de ne pas politiser un
événement qui ne devrait pas l'être ok
mais donc elle devrait y être elle
devrait être là selon vous elle devrait
être là exactement moi je suis refaire
ma frondeuse direct en avant de la scène
pour faire des beaux bébés je vous
signale que Jonathan Premier ministre du
gouvernement logo il sera seul en entier
de Québec solidaire il sera aussi
à la fête du 23 juin à Québec il y a pas
de député du Parti libéral je peux pas
vous dire s'ils ont été invités qu'ils
ont refusé ou s'ils ont pas été invités
du tout mais il y a pas de il y a pas de
libéraux ok est-ce qu'on est pas en
train de juste techniquement là parce
que deux cérémonies il y en a une devant
la fontaine tourini ou tous les partis
sont invités chaque année alors c'est
parti
on peut encore répondu d'habitude ils
sont là aussi c'est que pour la
célébration pour l'hommage au drapeau à
la Fontaine de Tourny est-ce que c'est
de ça
tout le monde
mais c'est le 24 juin puis pour
l'instant il y a Jonathan Julien qui a
qui est là Etienne Grandmont de Québec
solidaire et Bruno marchand je vois pas
de libéraux mais peut-être qu'ils y
seront ok mais c'est ceux qui sont
invités là il y a pas de dos seulement
elles sont invités mais c'est
l'événement où habituellement tous les
partis ils vont donc on parle ici c'est
l'événement sur les plaines c'est ce qui
précède l'é contraintes sur les plaines
c'est c'est ça qui fait l'objet de la
concrétiser
c'est surtout en rendant ça public le
fait qu'on y va pas de la façon dont
elle le fait que sa politique sa
politique l'événement alors que je peux
pas être plus d'accord qu'avec Françoise
que c'était viande là ne devrait
absolument pas être partisan c'est la
fête pas des policiers c'est la fête du
peuple québécois c'est la fête de tous
ceux qui vont s'y rendre tous ceux qui
vont regarder à la télévision qu'est-ce
qu'on veut on veut célébrer la chanson
la chanson québécoise puis oui on fait
appel à des artistes puis croyez moi
pendant des années puis Françoise parle
comme une ex député de nouveaux parties
démocratique moi je peux vous parler au
nom un peu des libéraux de l'époque
possède aujourd'hui mais à l'époque
c'est sûr que depuis 19
on a toujours senti que la fête du 24
juin appartenait aux parties québécois
c'est évident et c'est sûr que ceux qui
étaient pas piquent avaient certains
malaises de s'y rendre parce que
il remettait
fort puis je me rappelle des discussions
qu'on a eu combien de fois pendant que
j'étais au gouvernement sur le drapeau
appartient à tout le monde la fête
appartient à tout le monde mais mais on
sentait pas reçu à Broc grands ouverts
et c'est pas l'endroit non plus à mon
avis pour les discours comme tel je
comprends qu'ils font la petite
cérémonie avant puis on demande aux gens
de prendre la parole à la limite que le
premier ministre souhaite la bonne fête
à tous ces concitoyens oui moi je verrai
ça très bien mais est-ce qu'il faut que
vraiment puis là il parle pas comme chef
de la CAQ il parle comme premier
ministre des Québécois
on a pas besoin
de
le Premier ministre fait une vidéo
chaque année je suis d'accord
Jean-François mais cette fois-ci le
mouvement national de Québécois invite
le Parti québécois à prononcer un
discours dans la petite cérémonie même
là je dis on n'a pas besoin de discours
on a juste besoin de célébrer la fête
des Québécois et et des politiciens
complètement la fête on fait des des
maintenant on fait beaucoup de de on
travaille beaucoup d'enjeux sociaux de
façon transpartisable s'il y a une fête
qui doit être transpartisane c'est bien
celle du 24 juin alors je comprends pas
non plus comme Dimitri comment se fait
que le PQ en fait toute une histoire
parce que là il est encore une fois
entre souverainiste on s'attaque on
s'envoie des flèches moi je dis ça non
plus je comprends pas ça si j'étais
souverainiste je dirais mais non ils
sont nous arrêtons de nous attaquer on
peut avoir des divergences d'opinions on
peut avoir parti politique souverainiste
peut-être que le PQ aime pas ça avoir un
autre parti politique qui est qui est
souverainiste mais ça ça fait partie de
la démocratie alors
est-ce qu'il faut être piqué pour animer
la soirée Jean-François non je crois pas
puis en fait j'ai comme je suis très
écumé que dans dans mon approche j'ai
toujours pensé aussi que c'était
il y avait une difficulté à la fête
nationale qui avait si peu de place pour
les fédéralistes québécois et je tiens à
faire un coup de chapeau comme
militaire à la marche à la parade il a
chaque année puis personne ne doute qui
est fédéraliste et j'ai souvent marché
pas loin de lui il est bien accueilli
alors donc parfois la ministre de la
Culture était là du gouvernement libéral
bon c'est sûr que c'est le premier
ministre monsieur Couillard était venu
ce serait témoin clairement bien passé
mais je pense qu'il faut essayer essayer
d'avoir une présence d'être très
rassembleur maintenant moi je dis que
dans le cas particulier évidemment la
fête n'appartient pas au PQ mais le
choix que le MNQ a fait il aurait dû
savoir que c'était pas le plus
rassembleur il y avait énormément en
fait je ne connais aucun autre artiste
qui Émile Bilodeau qui est aussi
divisible au sein de la famille
nationaliste j'en connais aucun autre
que je peux pas vous citer un autre
artiste qui a souhaité la mort d'un
parti indépendantiste alors pourquoi le
choisir lui je pense que le manq a fait
une erreur mais le PQ ne demande pas de
le retirer non plus demande pas de le
canceler ils seront plus prudents je
pense l'an prochain
monde de la politique et de la culture
parce que tu sais je me disais qu'il y a
bien des artistes qui ont souhaité la
mort du Parti libéral puis ben la
communauté libérez-nous des libéraux
je ne voulais pas les nommer je leur en
fais pas rigueur mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que aussi chez le Parti
québécois ils ont cette habitude d'avoir
la communauté culturelle qui puis c'est
leur choix qui a vraiment sont de
tendance à beaucoup plus marqué mais les
libéraux n'ont jamais un jeu du compte
et là on dirait que le PQ ça les dérange
de voir que un de ceux de cette
communauté là dit ben non disons qu'on
le rejette le moi aimer le Bilodeau je
rejette le PQ mais en même temps un
moment donné il faut être au dessus de
tout ça pourquoi parce que la communauté
culturelle et ses artistes ce sont ceux
nos meilleurs ambassadeurs les meilleurs
ambassadeurs de notre culture de notre
identité pas toujours dans notre langue
mais oui il parle beaucoup de la défense
du français donc dans ce sens là moi je
me disais garde non on se met au dessus
de ça et on est là pour faire avancer
cette cause de la culture québécoise
plutôt que
une option politique en particulier
c'est quoi votre question
si parce que peu importe ce qu'il aurait
dit ici il avait tenu des propos
antisémites
on l'avait pas choisi
mais il en a pas de menu
de la loi sur la laïcité qu'elle était
misogyne dégradante et islamophobe mais
attention
fait référence à la deuxième guerre
mondiale et à l'holocauste honnêtement
aujourd'hui on peut être en chimie on
peut essayer là et dans ce sens-là je
pense qu'on peut pas aller aussi loin
dans cette comparaison là par rapport à
ce que aimer le Bilodeau dit il dit
qu'il est contre la loi 101 la conte la
loi 21 puis bon oui oui ça peut être
jugé
mais c'est quoi la limite de
l'acceptable c'est la limite de
l'acceptable
moi je pense que de dire qu'une loi qui
qui est appuyée par l'immense majorité
des Québécois et dégradants islamophobes
sur la ligne de ce qui est pas
rassembleur mais on a le droit de
critiquer quand même mais là
mais il est choisi pour rassembler c'est
cette définition tâche il y a Dimitri et
Françoise qui te traping Dimitri
deux choses rapidement mais premièrement
on est loin du grand soir si on dit vous
souvenez ce qui est contre la loi 21 ou
la loi 96 on vous veut pas
changer devenez fédéraliste excusez-moi
mais le PQ n'est pas dans une position
de faire des soustractions il doit faire
des additions et même même avec Monsieur
Bilodeau c'est un souverainiste donc
c'est quelqu'un qui ultimement peut voir
la lumière au bout du tunnel un jour et
dire non non le bon véhicule c'est le PQ
mais là tout ce que le PQ est en train
de faire c'est c'est de garantir qu'il
ne fera jamais ça et sur la fête
nationale c'est vrai surtout dans les
grandes villes comme Québec ou Montréal
il y a de gros discours nationalistes
même souvenais ce qui se font et à
l'époque de monsieur a peur on
choisissait toujours les plus petits
villages que ce soit Roberval ou à
Saint-Georges de Beauce comme c'est vrai
non mais c'est vrai imaginez imaginez
très bien imaginer Steven Harper
Montréal sur les Plaines d'Abraham on va
attendre les on va on va attendre des
gens huer jusqu'à jusqu'à Vancouver donc
et il ne faut pas oublier dernière chose
il ne faut pas oublier la fête nationale
c'est la saint Jean-Baptiste c'est une
fête qui est célébrée à travers le
Canada par les francophones une autre
une autre idée au Québec mais c'est
aussi une fête que célébrée à
Saint-Boniface où on nouveau banlieue
particulière au Québec
[Musique]
absolument
Françoise effectivement au Québec c'est
notre fête nationale ailleurs ça peut
être la saint Jean-Baptiste enfin je
veux pas remarquer dans ce débat là mais
j'allais dire on prévoit la même
discussion le même débat sur la fête
des 1er juillet à la fin du Canada
regardez
québécoises je t'ai pas invité à la fête
du Canada pas grand monde autre que le
ministre de la Culture et puis le
Premier ministre qui se donne toute le
padage et un gouverneur général à ce
genre de d'activité où il devrait
peut-être même pas être mais c'est pas
là et pas notre question je voulais
plutôt parler des artistes regardez le
nombre d'artistes québécois qui
acceptent d'aller se produire sur scène
la fête du Canada et qui se font
regarder travers par beaucoup de
souverain qu'est-ce que vous faites là
c'est un peu moins dans les dernières
années parce que on a compris que c'est
une célébration de l'artiste de notre
culture autant canadienne que québécois
puis une chance qu'on a la culture
québécoise parfois pour donner ce petit
côté intéressant à la culture canadienne
puis je veux pas insulter la culture
canadienne loin de moi mais ça aussi
c'était des débats ça peut être facile
pour un artiste québécois dire oui Sacha
fort bien que sa communauté était pour
la regarder de travers c'est toujours
assez difficile dans ces temps-là pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI